[Musica]
avevo scelto come prima foto la foto
della copertina dei Nirvana Nevermind Ma
poi temevo qualche coda di contenzioso e
ho trattato per questa più semplice c'è
un bambino che sta sicuro nell'acqua
come elemento primo il primo che ci
accoglie ne andremo materno elemento
primario essenziale da subito un senso
di come siano legate le parole acqua e
fiducia
è un connubio così potente che mi sono
venute in mente una miriade di
suggestioni di approfondimenti da
condividere con voi avrei per esempio
potuto parlarvi della fiducia dell'acqua
da bere cioè porre la domanda e
rispondere assieme a voi ma l'acqua che
beviamo quella che viene dal prodotto è
buona e sicura possiamo fidarci
dell'acqua che arriva alle nostre case e
avrei potuto rispondere con voi che sì è
una acqua sicura è un'acqua Iper
controllata tutti i giorni nella rete
del Veneto con prelievi sparsi nel
territorio analizziamo più di 1.900
parametri dell'acqua al giorno per
controllare che non ci sia nulla che non
rispetti i parametri di legge e
cerchiamo anche altre sostanze che non
sono previste dalla legge di cui magari
avrete anche sentito parlare sostanze
per foro alchimiche gemix ci sei o
quattro fitofarmaci
lo facciamo attraverso dei laboratori
che sono dei laboratori accreditati cioè
certificati da un soggetto terzo che si
sono messi in rete per fare ricerca
scambiarsi eccellenze sono davvero degli
scienziati e lo facciamo anche in
maniera preventiva Stiamo affrontando
450 piani di sicurezza dell'acqua non
soltanto per rincorrere le emergenze ma
anche per prevederle con un approccio
Riff Based cioè prevedendo Quali sono
gli eventi che possono rendere l'acqua
delle nostre fonti intaccata o dal punto
di vista della qualità o per la
continuità del servizio
Nonostante questo e nonostante l'acqua
italiana si è considerata l'acqua di
Migliore qualità in Europa in Italia
soltanto un cittadino su tre deve
l'acqua dell'Acquedotto e siamo tra i
più grandi consumatori al mondo se non
il primo consumatore al mondo di acqua
in bottiglia ne consumiamo
228 bottiglie a persona in Svezia ne
consumano 10
avrei potuto anche parlarvi dell'altro
tema che è stato toccato questa sera che
è quello della siccità dei cambiamenti
climatici e quindi di quel senso di
disagio che abbiamo provato quest'estate
quando per la prima volta ci siamo resi
veramente conto concretamente e non
soltanto perché lo leggevamo che la
risorsa acqua non era inesauribile che
poteva essere limitata nell'uso in
alcuni casi addirittura razionata
abbiamo visto sorgenti prosciugarsi
quest'estate materialmente viste falde
abbassate dimezzate abbiamo visto il po
a raggiungere la portata media di 80
metri cubi di secondo nella media del
periodo estivo raggiunge i 450 metri
cubi al secondo ed essere sopraffatto da
alcuni salino quindi avrei potuto
parlarvi della riflessione che diventa
essenziale adesso
tra più soggetti che utilizzano l'acqua
che la natura produce per noi l'acqua
dolce una riflessione che devono fare
per
limitarne
l'uso e lo spreco che ne facciamo
una riflessione che dovrà fare il
comparto agricolo senz'altro ripensare
le colture ripensare il modo di
irrigarle
attrezzarsi per utilizzare l'acqua da
riuso cioè quella che esce per esempio
dalla depurazione con i trattamenti
necessari dovrà ripensarci anche il
mondo dell'Industria che comunque ne
utilizza un 20%, anche questa dovrà
pensare a prodotti pesati rispetto alla
water footprint Cioè a quanto dispendio
di acqua comunque c'è per la produzione
di alcuni prodotti ovviamente dobbiamo
pensarci noi come consumatori perché
siamo dei grandi consumatori di acqua in
Italia rispetto al resto del paese
europei e ovviamente ci devono pensare i
gestori i gestori prelevano il 20%
dell'acqua dolce
però tantissime volte
mi è stata posta la domanda ma anche se
diciamo solo un 20%, c'è un enorme
spreco di quest'acqua perché le reti
sono un colabrodo quante volte l'avrete
sentito dire questa cosa le reti sono un
po' la brodo e quindi c'è una domanda
che nasce spesse volte quasi stizzita Ma
perché non le riparate queste reti
perché non limitate queste perdite e
quindi è per rispondere a questa domanda
che ho pensato di concentrare lo speech
di oggi su un terzo tema che è quello
della
del dell'acqua legata alla Finanza è
legata agli strumenti finanziari
perché
è vero
ci sono delle reti che sono da
sostituire da riparare questo significa
distrettualizzarle ricercare le perdite
occulte riparare le perdite che così si
scoprono e anche banalmente sostituire
le condotte che si rompono questo
significa un enorme fabbisogno a cui
dobbiamo mettere mano che è un
fabbisogno di 5 miliardi di euro l'anno
è un fabbisogno enorme pensate che
soltanto per contrastare la crisi
sicitosa di quest'estate il Veneto ha
bisogno di 600 milioni di investimenti
di nuove opere
Ma com'è che si affronta una spesa come
questa al netto di finanziamenti
straordinari come possono essere quelle
del pnrr tutte questi investimenti così
ingenti li sosteniamo noi cittadini
attraverso la bolletta che paghiamo
mensilmente o mensilmente cioè
attraverso la tariffa Allora adesso vi
chiedo di fare una riflessione assieme a
me anzi un rapido calcolo impostando
una operazione aritmetica rispetto al
fabbisogno che avete visto ipotizzando
quale potrebbe essere il peso della
nostra bolletta con questa formula
semplicissima Che cara produce il
calcolo della tariffa
è una formula che fa venire la nausea
anche a me fortuna che c'è qualche
esperto in azienda più bravo di me nel
definire la tariffa
della mia azienda ma è importante capire
una cosa perché non c'è fiducia senza
conoscenza e quindi
Perdonatemi se li faccio vedere questa
cosa complessa ma è importante capire
che la nostra bolletta Quindi la nostra
tariffa copre sostanzialmente ma molto
per semplificare i costi operativi di
gestione e quelli che noi tecnicamente
che abbiamo cartex cioè le nuove opere
cioè gli investimenti Ma com'è che
funziona nel nostro metodo tariffario
che il gestore realizza le opere le
collauda le mette in funzione le metti
in esercizio e due anni dopo il costo di
quelle opere entra in tariffa entra due
anni dopo e per il valore
dell'ammortamento del bene Quindi se un
tu va in ammortamento in 40 anni due
anni dopo che l'ho realizzato che è
entrato in funzione che funziona bene
Entra un quarantesimo del suo costo
perché vi spiego questo perché si
intuisce chiaramente quanto è importante
sia la leva finanziaria per sostenere il
sistema idrico perché il denaro in
tariffa entra almeno due anni dopo e
soltanto per il valore dell'ammortamento
questo
comporta una leva bancaria per esempio
che però non è perfettamente allineata
al tipo di beni che noi produciamo in
qualsiasi azienda è buona prassi che
l'ammortamento finanziario segua
l'ammortamento dei beni Come vi dicevo
le tubazioni hanno una ammortamento di
40 anni alcuni impianti di 50 anni
quindi normalmente un finanziamento che
anche nella vostra esperienza è
normalmente decennale è poco allineato
con il tipo di investimenti che dobbiamo
fare noi allora in Veneto abbiamo
pensato a uno strumento particolare che
è stato definito dalla Banca europea
degli investimenti come l'operazione di
Finanza strutturata più di successo
degli ultimi dieci anni e più originale
degli ultimi 10 anni in Europa
i gestori veneti erano un po' agevolati
perché noi ci siamo messi insieme come
avete sentito la rappresentazione e
lavoriamo insieme compriamo materiali
insieme i reagenti Lavoriamo insieme
quindi c'è una reciproca conoscenza Ci
scopiamo le nostre conoscenze migliori
da questa conoscenza approfondita e
dalla fiducia che c'era tra noi nel
lavorare insieme mettendo proprio le
mani in pasta
abbiamo pensato un'operazione
finanziaria che ci consentisse di avere
dei finanziamenti di durata più
commisurata all'ammortamento dei nostri
beni quindi abbiamo avuto accesso ad un
mercato molto più grande che non fosse
soltanto il mercato bancario
la Banca europea degli investimenti ci
ha sostenuto con Un'operazione che noi
abbiamo denominato Hydro bond e che
funziona così ci sono le società
emittenti che emettono le proprie
obbligazioni
che vengono acquistate da una società
veicolo E che le mette nel mercato dei
finanziatori finanziatori che non ci
avrebbero filati come piccoli gestori
individualmente perché parliamo di
mercati importanti
il primo la prima operazione del 2016 è
stata sostenuta dalla Banca europea
degli investimenti e poi il mercato ha
preso fiducia nei confronti di questi
piccoli gestori che però si erano messi
insieme e i finanziatori gli investitori
sono stati poi la cassa depositi e
prestiti e poi anche dei fondi privati
dei fondi pensione e fondi di cittadini
anche di altri Stati
questa fiducia del mercato poggia anche
su un altro operazione
che vorrei approfondire con voi questo
quadratino qua sotto c'è scritto ce è il
Credit nasman questa parola non sta
altro che a significare una solidarietà
tra i vari gestori che hanno partecipato
a questa operazione
quando voi andate in banca a fare
un'operazione di finanziamento la banca
vi chiede della garanzia quindi per
esempio l'ipoteca sulla casa che è stata
acquistando in questo caso noi non
possiamo dare i nostri beni in garanzia
nel momento in cui viene estesa una
tubazione ha fatto un impianto di
depurazione di potabilizzazione quando
entra in uso diventa automaticamente
demagno idrico e il patrimonio della
collettività e non è attaccabile dal
creditore che non è soddisfatto del
pagamento della rata E quindi dovevamo
inventarci una garanzia diversa e la
garanzia che abbiamo messo in campo è
proprio questo credito enancement quindi
se
uno dei gestori che hanno fatto
l'emissione singolarmente non paga la
propria rata
soccorre qualche altro gestore capite
bene che è un atto di fiducia importante
che è stato possibile soltanto perché
lavoravamo insieme da 12 anni e quindi
conoscevamo l'un l'altro
l'efficienza dell'azienda la solidità
patrimoniale e la solita anche
finanziaria reciprocamente
Questo esempio puntuale
sulla fiducia che il mercato ha avuto
nei nostri confronti e la fiducia che è
stata la base di questa operazione
originale di finanziamento che ci ha
consentito di fare
reperire nel mercato
623 milioni di Finanza Tra l'altro
Finanza Green a sostegno soltanto di
investimenti che avessero una ricaduta
ambientale o sul binario di cittadini mi
porta quindi a fare una riflessione
finale anche se muove da un elemento
così tecnico quindi finanziario e cioè
che nelle
gestioni complesse come quelle che ho
cercato di illustrarvi come quella del
mondo del servizio idrico integrato il
successo del risultato Dipende per buona
metà della fiducia
e la fiducia si conquista con l'altra
metà che è fatta di azioni concrete Non
di dichiarazioni che si realizzano di
giorno in giorno di anno in anno e
goccia la goccia
Grazie
[Applauso]